[Musique]
je me présente à voir maman ça étudiants
de l ue de la formation pour dans ma
boîte donc la première pour mot sur des
idiots alors où présenter au point que
j'ai pu atteindre ce niveau je vais un
peu vous raconter leur histoire
quand j'étais aux primaires je me disais
se voir en cela par mes camarades de
classe
je ne savais pas pourquoi c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai dit par contre
j'étais souvent timides ou parce que
chaque vendredi je venais à l'école avec
mon ballon et une petite cure et des
consonnes et je courais dans la cour et
je vous mets un jeu remarqué que ça a
dérangé et directeur récemment watts
puis au fur et à mesure que le temps
passe et je ne me sentais pas à l'aise
je me sentais vraiment pas les avec mes
camarades parce que pour moi elle
n'aimait pas nommé mais pas du coup je
m'étais souvent avec la liga et ceux qui
m'avaient poussé encore une fois la
chance que j'ai dit c'est parfois les
parents pour moi c'est bien parents ne
sont pas comme les autres parce que sans
le savoir il m'emmenait à des activités
des loisirs pour enfants
donc depuis tout petit j'avais commencé
à faire des activités sportives comme le
foot le taekwondo la natation est aussi
le suivre
j'étais tout le temps j'étais tout le
temps et les paroles d'entre eux soit de
jouer au foot ce délai à la piscine
l'univers du polar sans me sentir un peu
en plus en bonheur
pour me dire que je vais essayer des
soucis de côté et je vais m'en visé puis
une fois jamais été invité avec quelques
ensembles à une émission de radio locale
où nous avons posé une question et
aurait dû être plus tard on y fait cinq
ou six heures autour de la table donc je
stresse est parce que financière est
parfaite pour moi un modèle c'était ma
mère parce que chaque matin je la voyais
sortir avec un simple ou aller au boulot
mais je ne serais pas ce qu'ils
faisaient
donc j'ai stressé vraiment tu vois des
enfants
on se regardait tous personne ne savait
pas des plus grands pas dire oui et
avait un qui s'est élevé lundi qu'il est
un pilote s est de la chine avait comme
aussi pilote la peur parce qu'on
pressent les allées où elle s'arrêtera
dire c'était à mon tour et moi
absolument j'avais aussi des problèmes
de de rebondir de landal je ne savais
pas pour nous exprimer et réellement
pour une direction mais on avait demandé
et malheureusement j'avais des pires
aussi arrivé à la maison cette scène m'a
vraiment touché arrive à la maison je ne
s'activera je n'étais pas contente du
tout le monde je m'étais rapproché de ma
mère et je les avais posé la question
c'est contre boulot elle a juste révélé
lundi pourquoi donc je lui avais un peu
raconté
qu'est ce qui se serait passé dans la
journée elle m'a dit écoute moi je
travaille pour une ong
n'est ce pas ce qu'on pouvait les
laisser nous expliquer je compterai
l'écran parce que j'avais entre 8 et 11
ans donc ce n'était pas évident puis je
lui ai posé la question et mon père fait
quoi et nous a dit il est architecte
mais ça aussi je comprenais pas après il
a commencé à me dire bon celui qui
construit des maisons tu vois les
maisons c'est son travail
en gros c'était même pas l'architecte
était un entrepreneur dans le bts vas-y
du coup elle avait dix architectes
j'étais là ok je connais pas son chéri
je vais te dis non l'administration
s'est pas fait pour toi ont tué c'est
pas fait pour toi elle a dit soi quand
on perd je vous jure depuis le jour là
tout a changé
parce que à chaque fois qu'une
intervenante cheval à 17 je voyais
jamais adressé des gestes pour savoir
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qui le rend
l'air aussi fort parce qu'un veilleuse
il dit c'était un super match j'étais
vraiment fois puis j'avais et je la leur
projet ils avaient posé des questions
sur son métier c'est en ce moment qu'il
avait commencé à expliquer qu'il veut
pour commencer il fallait dessiner
il fallait faire des dessins donc du
coup je l'avais suivi j'avais commencé à
faire des petits dessins de petites
maisons pour dire voilà c'est ma maison
de rêve parce que lui la reconstruire
leurs maisons
c'est li kath et des planches moi je
veux faire mieux que lui c'est ça la clé
de tout depuis tout petit
donc j'avais commencé à faire des plans
et devis et après j'avais j'ai commencé
à utiliser des personnes qui meurent à
nu ni avec darcos bloch et construisez
des petites maisons et ce n'est pas
évident c'est un imposteur parce qu'en
ce moment je n'avais pas vraiment d'amis
mon seul mathieu patients en ce moment
c'était le foot et c'était prix de la
soirée
du coup je vais continuer à faire ça
joue
tu n'y as pas celle concernant les jurés
puis une fois et au collège est aberrant
de nos professions qui les avait dit est
de faire une requête d'une maison juste
la raison que vous espérez et moi quand
j'avais déjà pris de l'avancé dessus au
lieu de faire une raison avec l'allemand
fait tout un village
un village avec un puits des tisanes i
mode
arusha bras tout encore temps du coup il
était tellement quand on demande qu'il
avait montré sa tous ses collègues et à
l'art démontré sa au directeur parce que
pour lui la régissent de manière un truc
mais moi j'ai sauté parfois les gens
puis après ça je m'étais dit je fais des
efforts plus le monde est content donc
je suis contente aussi après ça j'avais
commencé au lieu de demander pardon je
prenais des planches vraiment des
planches et j'avais de redire mon père
je veux passer à l'étape suivante donc
et pour moi c'était les planches il me
ramenait des planches
mais avant de nous ramener ça le disait
le plan qu'est ce que tu aimerais faire
et avant que j'étais petit j'avais un
dessin anglais que je rêve allait
souvent la famille vers l'italie où les
enfants avaient participé à une course
en voiture et avant de participer à la
course tu veux construire tout en même
temps voiture du coup j'avais eu la
décence j'étais venu auprès de montage
politique julien vetiq si ça je veux
mais quand je n'arrivais toujours pas
exprimé ce que je voulais réellement
il m'avait dit de dessiner donc c'était
en ce moment il a commencé à me plaindre
et à être mon mentor par rapport à tout
ce que je voulais faire et de entre une
semaine deux semaines plus tard j'avais
créé ma petite voiture blanche où je
pouvais rentrer les jeunes pousses
étaient donc je voulais aller loin et au
lieu de faire une petite radio j'ai
arrêté tout pourquoi pas un travail et
qu'on les paye donc j'avais comme ainsi
s'agit des français c'est comme si
j'étais sur mon chantier j'étais
labrosse qui avait personne pour me dire
j'en pense que je vais parents me disais
me disais-je allemands ils voulaient me
pousser et voir ce que je pouvais aller
mon imagination
parce que vraiment grâce à être j'avais
des idées folles n'y avait pas de blocus
du goût la première semaine j'étais en
train de travailler et malheureusement
j'avais piétinant vous donc ça m'avait
dit si j'étais vraiment plaisir
mon fils était enflé en ce moment à
redire
les cliniques ou qu'on puisse me faire
une piqûre pour éviter il râle a dit aux
autres la nuit là j'avais souffert
j'avais vraiment souffert parce que
j'étais blessé je veux simplement quoi
faire je disais est ce que je vais pas
vous donner ce petit projet que j'avais
besoin d'un ou deux devaient avancer
grand mère me regarde avec pitié elle
parce que pour moi le maire quand tu as
mal dans le ciel général donc du coup je
n'imaginais pas sa souffrance aussi le
une semaine plus tard j'étais vraiment
guéri j'étais retourné sur mon petit
chantier je voulais pas abandonner parce
que je voulais leur montrer que je
voulais le montrer que j'étais forte que
je pouvais faire les plus jeunes je
n'abandonne pas c'était ça mon objectif
bien parti que je n'avais encore revêtir
mais cette fois ci avant d'y aller
j'avais un peu aménagés et portait des
bottes mais ça ne suffisait pas
j'avais oublié de faire un rappel de
délimiter cette heure parce que c'était
pas à l'intérieur de l'appareil était à
l'espérer que je m'étais blessé après ça
encore une troisième fois j'étais revenu
parce que je voulais pas abandonner je
voulais que le petit oiseau irene raison
c'était son but
donc après j'ai finalement pu construire
la cabane qui faisait 2 mètres de
hauteur et à mettre 50 de l'argent
savoir comment gérer les plans mais
comment c'était une vague plus grosse
fierté aussi
non
les années plus tard j'avais j'avais
déjà pris l'initiative de n'ai jamais
abandonné et de continuer tout ce que je
faisais quelques années plus tard après
après avoir une longueur
j'ai juré t on avaient inscrits dans les
universités en droit mais je me sentais
pas à l'aise parce que j'avais déjà
l'esprit de vouloir apprendre mais page
et d'avoir un diplôme sans apprendre
parce que là où j'étais je ne prenais
pas en réalité pour moi c'était dignité
et comme par magie
j'étais allé à l'orphelinat pour un
temps visé par une amie elle était
revenue elle m'avait parlé d'une
université une bonne université que qui
veut qui va bientôt s'ouvrir et 7
universités c'était un tuyau elle
m'avait elle ne parlait plus à me parler
plusieurs lisez awards ça c'est mon
école c'est ça si sa mort elle
j'aimerais devenir comme c est ce qu ont
ces grandes personnes j'aimerais qu'on
me pousse à aller à dépasser mes limites
servent les parents ont fait le premier
pas mais j'aimerais avoir aussi un autre
une autre personne qui me pousse kivu
qui va me pousser à aller plus loin
donc on m'avait expliqué et franchement
l'université c'est l environnement que
je voulais ça pour ça me permettait
d'aller loin yahvé peuple qui sait tout
ce que je voulais faire et tout ce que
je pourrai faire c'est la bonne a dit
c'était de travailler dur et de jared
reste baisser les bras puis j'avais
intérêt cette université avant
d'intégrer j'ai stressé je stresse et à
mort parce que pour moi j'allais pas
intégrer il fallait être excellent
partout et moi je ne me voyais pas elle
se gagne surtout que j'avais des
difficultés à exprimer
j'aimerais vraiment passionnant j'étais
rouge et et on avait appelé des états
unis
il avait été sélectionné le jour là j'ai
vraiment contente
après plus le temps passait plus
j'adorais l'université parce que
franchement je ne regrettais absolument
pas les années que j'avais perdu un ami
et dans le passé parce que je me disais
rien n'est fait au hasard le destin
le destin a été tracée pour tout le
monde donc il faut juste que je suis au
chômage puis en quand j'étais en premier
il y avait les élections de deux
délégués de classe je voulais essayer
parce que bien avant dans la nacion
l'université j'étais aussi délégué je
voulais aussi été partagé avec mes amis
parce que j'avais cet amour-là de
partager ce que et je sais faire aussi
d'aider les gens à lire a lieu loin mais
malheureusement j'avais les cheveux
parce qu'il y avait plus de quelques
mois là cette année passée dans le
deuxième il y avait les élections pour
le ngcc en question la cour mentionne la
vie où je voulais qu'on l'écouté parce
que je voulais aussi désolé car c'était
ça c'était ça il fallait que je j'arrive
à faire ça mais malheureusement il y
avait plus sage que moi et bien à la
dernière position
c'étaient les élections présidentielles
à diou au début je ne voulais pas du
trait de présidente
c'était mon premier ministre obtient qui
devait être président et moi je voulais
je vais juste leur compagnie après qu'on
s'était vu je voyais comment elle a
toujours des la situation évolue je lui
avais dit écoute et si je devenais
présidente les problèmes comme ça on va
essayer de travailler ensemble parce que
je sais que je suis plus en contact avec
les étudiants que toi et je sais que je
les écoute facilement j'aime bien
discuter avec et j'aime savoir qu'est-ce
qui est ce qu'il a dit ensuite il avait
accepté
donc on était parti pour les élections
c'était vraiment la folie son campus on
avait créé des banderoles mariage
affiché partout où nous c'était un hôtel
avec mais aussi c'était en été en quête
de réussite
je ne savais pas de salaire pas pour moi
j'étais juste part si parce que j'avais
échoué j'avais échoué mais que bon
troisièmement c'est toute l'université
s'est passé pour possible que je
réussisse même mai dernier jour le jour
des élections qu'on l'avait appelé mon
nom et qu'on avait dit que j'avais
doublé mais deux candidats de terroir
je n'arrivais même pas à sourire pour
les autres n'utiliser mais pourquoi tu
t'y fais je disais au fus foutu je vous
dis lui les vraies choses commencent
après vont par la suite absolument avec
un dieu surtout quand on nous met dans
les situations de comment dire vous êtes
vraiment sur le terrain
du coup c'est vraiment difficile est
aussi actuellement j'aimerais remercier
tous les étudiants de l ue pour tout ce
qu'ils font du début jusqu'à la fin
parce que c'est pas facile d'enchaîner
les études et aussi les activités
c'est vraiment sans pratiquer le cerveau
mais quand même on tient le coup et
c'est une formation excellente et on a
choisi ça donc on va continuer parce que
c'est le rêve de toujours lent fait
maintenant la seule chose que je peux
vous dire est ce que j'ai retenu dans la
vie ce que j'adore y a pas de blocage
quand tu perds sévère plus du père
ferait plus tu as trois buts et quant à
des buts c'est un rêve que tiendraient
voir réaliser donc c'est quoi lancement
jamais baissé les bras et aussi faire en
sorte que demain et camarades aussi
croit en toi et voirie l'attention
culturelle diffusée plus tard j'aimerais
que grâce à ses capacités et de grosses
personnes et de l'emploi mais surtout
donner la chance à ceux qui n'ont pas eu
la même chose que moi ce que l'on voit
et ça parce que pour moi je me dis que
c'est vraiment une chance c'est une
chance pour moi d'être devant et s'était
excusé une chance pour moi d'avoir eu
des parents que j'ai que j'ai
actuellement
et aussi c'est une chance pour moi est
de me dire que ce que j'ai envie d'un
enfant son nom publiquement mais encore
plus m'a donné de la force ont continué
dans le futur
[Applaudissements]